alors voilà nous y voici à ce budget
budget prude à hostert diront certains
les cibles budgétaires sont humains tenu
du déficit zéro dans deux ans mais il ya
un prix à payer donc restrictions
budgétaires en santé et en éducation et
hausse des tarifs en garderie david
gêne-t-il et les faisait rire c'est
probablement un budget morny qui
deviendra la plateforme économique
péquiste à la veille d'une élection mais
parce que le contexte financier est
serré on propose une mesure qui pourrait
déplaire à certains parents après dix
ans de gel le coût des places en cpe
penserait de septembre à vis dollar puis
1 9 dollar l'an prochain pour les années
suivantes les tarifs sont indexés
nicolas marceau estime qu'on n'avait
plus le choix il faut stabiliser le
financement de nos services de garde
reste qu'en éducation les budgets
augmenterait de 3 % mais les commissions
scolaires sont dans le collimateur leur
nombre devrait être réduit
on pense ainsi économisé 125 millions en
santé oms propose un virage majeur quant
au financement
on veut ajuster les paiements aux
établissements en fonction de la
quantité et de la qualité des soins
offerts
là aussi les budgets augmentent de 3%
pour respecter cette cible on souhaite
entre autres reportés les hausses de
salaires des médecins
moi je pense que ce serait raisonnable
aussi d'étaler ses eaux cela d'autant
plus qu'on est dans un contexte où
ailleurs au canada
il ya eu un ralentissement considérable
la progression des médecins même volonté
de négocier avec les fonctionnaires et
de lier leurs salaires à la croissance
économique ce défi c'est que nous
disposons de ressources limitées pour la
rémunération
preuve que les ressources sont limitées
dans les ministères autre que la santé
et l'éducation
on parle d'une baisse de 0,8 pour cent
des dépenses
on le voit nicolas marceau n'a pas
beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre
le déficit sera d'ailleurs 2,1 milliards
750 millions mais on pense toujours
atteindre l'équilibré budgétaire l'an
prochain une bonne partie qui va venir
effectivement de la péréquation la bouée
de sauvetage de québec c'est ottawa les
transferts fédéraux sont plus élevés
vues et augmente de façon marquée l'an
prochain pas de hausse de taxes ou
d'impôts mais une nouvelle offensive
pour lutter contre le travail au noir
on vise l'industrie de la construction
et les bars où on instaure un système de
factures obligatoire même si on a peu de
chances de se rendre jusque là les
libéraux votre aide de toute façon
contre ce budget il ya bien sûr un ton
électoraliste clair c'est un lancement
de campagne électorale puisque un budget
à mon avis la caq votre est aussi contre
le budget et souligne la dépendance du
québec envers les paiements de
péréquation d'ottawa j'espère que
monsieur marceau va au moins envoyer une
carte de saint valentin au ministre des
finances du canada
je ne vois pas de différences
substantielles dans le budget actuel
avec la vision du parti libéral est la
vision de la coalition à venir qui s'il
ya comme prévu une campagne électorale
le prochain gouvernement reprendra cet
exercice et déposera un autre budget
d'ici l'été ici david gêne-t-il radio
canada québec
je rejoins gérald et sébastien d'abord
gerald qu'est ce qu'on retient du point
de vue économique de ce budget ben je
vous dirais que le défi du contrôle des
dépenses demeure entier c'est le
vérificateur général qui en parlaient
qui voulait qu'ils trouvaient ça
ambitieux le contrôle des dépenses mais
qui voulez des informations détaillées
tout est à faire et on va le faire pas
parce qu on stimule l'économie ou parce
qu'on crée de la richesse mais parce
qu'on augmente les tarifs les tarifs de
garderie le tarif patrimonial
d'hydro-québec c'est cette année que ça
a commencé il ya une autre au ski devant
la régie de l'énergie présentement
l'évasion fiscale forte pression aussi
sur le système de santé sur les autres
ministères sur les commissions scolaires
c'est un contrôle des dépenses patrice
qui est extrêmement fragile
sébastien donc un budget mort-né
mais un budget qui servira de plate
forme économique pour le gouvernement
marois
sébastien
juste en selle sur la table électorale
qu'il est en train de monter depuis
plusieurs semaines parce que pensez-y on
est engagé dans un crescendo qui va
culminer par le déclenchement
d'élections d'ici trois semaines
mme marois au cours des dernières
semaines a parlé de souveraineté en
écartant et si des questions qui
pourraient être embarrassantes lors
d'une campagne électorale sur ce thème
là elle a parlé de pétrole à l'île
d'anticosti
aujourd'hui elle dépose un budget dans
lequel il ya une décision qui va
déplaire aux parents d'enfants qui vont
dans des garderies subventionnées en
augmentant les tarifs mais au moins la
table est mise pour écarter de
discussion problématique cet enjeu de
l'augmentation des tarifs de garderie et
d'ici trois semaines
elle devrait déclencher des élections
maintenant reste plus qu'à déterminer la
date parce que ce sera le 7 avril le 14
avril
selon nos informations madame marois
penche un peu plus du côté du 14 avril
le temps de tourner la page sur ce
budget d'occuper le terrain et de
déclencher les élections